halten sie weiter abstand voneinander
mindestens 1,5 meter halten sie die
husten regeln ein
werden sie in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln unterwegs sind oder in
einem geschäft tragen sie zusätzlich
einen mund nasen bedeckung um andere zu
schützen
diese mund nasen bedeckung werden eben
auch alters macht alltags masken genannt
die zahlen müssen auf einem level
bleiben mit dem das gesundheitssystem
umgehen kann
am besten ist es sie so weit wie möglich
zu drücken
wenn die fallzahlen in die höhe schießen
kann das gesundheitssystem immer noch
sehr schnell überlastet werden dann
können patienten nicht mehr bestmöglich
versorgt werden das hätte gravierende
folgen nicht nur für ärzte
pflegepersonal und co mit 90 patienten
sondern für uns alle
dieses szenario müssen wir weiterhin
verhindern
wir alle können und müssen dazu
beitragen die fallzahlen klein zu halten
die kurve ein neuer erkrankungen flach
aus solidarität gegenüber dem
medizinischen personal aus solidarität
gegenüber den risikogruppen und aus
solidarität mit der gesellschaft
insgesamt mit jedem von uns jeder kann
schwer an cupid 19 erkranken
das betrifft nicht nur risikogruppen
jeder ihren plötzlich medizinische hilfe
benötigen und auf eine klinik angewiesen
sein
wir müssen uns daher alle weiterhin an
die empfehlungen halten ich weiß wie
schwer das geld und wie schwierig die
situation für viele menschen gerade ist
aber es gibt keine andere möglichkeit um
cupid 19 einzudämmen ist es natürlich
weiter auch ganz entscheidend dass
infektion schnell erkannt und
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgt werden dass
die risikogruppen vor allen dingen in
den heim besser geschützt werden und es
muss weiterhin intensiv getestet werden
um ein genaueres bild der lage zu
bekommen
noch ein hinweis zum tragen von dem so
genannten mund nasenschutz oder der mund
nase bedeckung es gilt ganz
grundsätzlich mehr akute atemwegs und
thomas hat bleibt bitte zu hause
für alle anderen um sich selbst und
andere vor ansteckung zu schützen ist es
immer noch das wichtigste abstand zu
halten mindestens 1,5 meter gute
händehygiene und husten unis regeln
beachten
in einigen situationen empfehlen wir
zusätzlich das tragen einer mund nasen
bedeckung um andere zu schützen
wir empfehlen dass wenn mehrere menschen
sich länger im öffentlichen raum
insbesondere in geschlossenen räumen
aufhalten oder man den abstand von
mindestens 1,5 meter nicht einhalten
kann zum beispiel am arbeitsplatz in
geschäften in bussen und bahnen und je
mehr mit menden menschen mitmachen desto
besser desto eher kann eine weitere
ausbreitung verlangsamt werden aber ganz
wichtig zu verstehen
die mund nase bedecken muss richtig
getragen und gepflegt werden
dazu gibt es hinweise zb bei der pca und
die mund nase bedeckung ersetzt nicht
andere empfehlung es muss weiter abstand
gehalten werden
es müssen sich regelmäßig und gut die
hände gewaschen werden und die husten
und niesen regeln müssen beachtet werden
der mond die mund nasen bedeckung ist
ein zusätzlicher baustein und sie ist
allein kein sicherer schutz vor allen
dingen nicht für sich selbst
und bitte beachten sie auch
medizinischer mund nasenschutz oder die
ffw zwei masten sollen die medizinischen
personal vorbehalten bleiben ich möchte
nun zu den zahlen kommen und dort die
wichtigsten werte nennen es ist gelungen
in den letzten wochen einen deutlich
geringeren erträglichen anstieg der
fallzahlen geht in der letzten woche
gegenüber der vorwoche zu erreichen
für die letzten tage gilt aber weiter
vorsicht denn es kann hier noch zu
nachmeldungen kommen die das bild wieder
etwas verändern
zudem sehen wir starke regionale
unterschiede bei den fall
gestern lag die produktionszahl bei etwa
0,9
auch bei dieser zahl gibt es starke und
große regionale unterschiede im mittel
steckt aber immer noch beinahe jede
person eine weitere mit saas kopf mit
dem saas koch 2 virus an in denen in der
letzten woche haben wir zudem den bisher
größten anstieg bei der zahl der
todesfälle gesehen am 16.4 2020 waren
ist 315 neue übermittelte todesfälle an
einem tag
das führt zu einem kontinuierlichen
anstieg des verstorbenen anteils in den
letzten wochen auf aktuell 3,2 prozent
es wird auch weiterhin von ausbrüchen in
alters und pflegeheimen sowie in
krankenhäusern berichtet die
behandlungskapazitäten insbesondere auch
bei den intensiv und beatmungs plätzen
ist zur zeit ausreichend vorhanden
mittlerweile werden auch alle kliniken
mit intensivbetten in dem entsprechenden
intensiv register von baby und robert
koch-institut erfasst beim derzeitigen
stand sind keine engpässe in den
nächsten tagen absehbar aber auch das
kann regional bei ausbrüchen
unterschiedlich werden voraussetzung
dafür ist dass es so bleibt die anzahl
an neuen erkrankungsfällen darf nicht
wieder ansteigen im vergleich mit denen
mit der anderen staaten weltweit möchte
ich einige staaten nennen
in den vereinigten staaten gibt es
zurzeit 759 oder fast 700 60.000 fälle
mit rund 40.700 todesfällen dass es ein
fall verstorbenen anteil von 5,4 prozent
in spanien 196.000 fälle mit 20.000 500
todesfällen einfall verstorbenen antrag
von 10 4 prozent in italien 179.000
fälle mit 23.700 todesfällen ein
verstorbene leiter von 13,2 prozent
in deutschland haben wir gegenwärtig 143
1500 fälle mit etwa 4600 todesfälle
das ist ein fall verstorbenen anteil von
3,2 prozent
mittlerweile sind mehr als 2,3 millionen
coup 19 fälle weltweit bekannt nahezu
alle länder sind betroffen besonders
aktiv ist das ausbruchsgeschehen in
nordamerika und europa die ausführlichen
zahlen für die welt finden sie auf den
seiten der weltgesundheitsorganisation
und des icd sie wir haben darauf auch
von unserer cupid 19 seite verlinkt die
gesamttendenz in deutschland beträgt 173
fälle pro 100000 einwohner das sind also
etwa 1,7 fälle pro 1000 einwohner
und auch diese variiert stark in
deutschland in bayern zb mit 293 fällen
pro 100.000 einwohnern eine hohe zahl
und in mecklenburg vorpommern mit 41.000
mit 41 fällen pro 100.000 einwohnern
eine gegenüber recht niedrige zahl in
den letzten tagen wurden etwas über
unter 2.000 fälle pro tag neu
übermittelt die zahl der genesenen wird
auf 95.000 200 geschätzt
die fallzahl und die zahl der gelesenen
wird täglich aktualisiert sie können sie
detailliert auf unserem dashboard auf
unserer website abrufen
es gibt jeden tag auch einen neuen
situationsbericht mit einer
lage-einschätzung und weiteren daten den
sie ebenfalls auf unserer website finden
und der immer gegen nachmittag bzw am
frühen abend aktualisiert wird
die betroffenen personen in deutschland
sind im durchschnitt 50 jahre alt dieses
durchschnittsalter ist also leicht
gestiegen männer und frauen in etwa
gleich betroffen rund für rund vier
fünftel der übermittelten fälle liegen
uns informationen über die häufigkeit
der symptome vor husten mit 50% fieber
mit 42% schnupfen mit 21 prozent und
auch geschmacks und geruchs verlust
werden insgesamt häufig berichtet aber
erst seit dieser woche systematisch in
den meldedaten erfasst dass es ein
symptom was relativ neu entdeckt worden
ist wir haben jetzt um
melde maske entsprechend angepasst
werden dazu dann in zukunft auch zahlen
für deutschland haben in 17 prozent der
fälle wurde eine hospitalisierung
übermittelt das entspricht einfach
18.800 fällen und von den etwa 113.000
fällen mit entsprechenden angaben dazu
für 2,5 prozent der übermittelten fälle
ist bekannt dass sie eine
lungenentzündung entwickelt haben
ich hatte bereits erwähnt dass der
anteil der verstorbenen unter den
gemeldeten fällen in deutschland nun 3,2
prozent beträgt diese zahl der
todesfälle und der anteil der
verstorbene es in den letzten tagen
kontinuierlich gestiegen
das liegt zum einen daran dass wir mehr
ausbrüche in alters und pflegeheimen und
krankenhäusern sehen wo besonders
risikogruppen getroffen sind zum anderen
sehen wir aber auch generell viele
erkrankungen bei älteren menschen die
verstorbenen personen waren im
durchschnitt 81 jahre alt 86 prozent der
verstorbenen waren 70 jahre oder älter
es befinden sich noch viele kurven 19
fälle in stationärer behandlung und wir
leihen müssen leider auch mit weiteren
todesfällen in der zukunft rechnen
am freitag haben wir auf unser cupid 19
website eine übersicht über die
erfassungssysteme publiziert die
sogenannten syriens systeme
dort können sie detailliert nachlesen
dass wir eben außer den meldezahlen noch
weitere daten erfassen und wie wir das
tun und was diese zahlen und sagen
gestern haben wir weiterhin auf unserem
dashboard eine weitere epidemiologische
kurve ergänzt und zwar eine
epidemiologische kurve nach erkrankungs
datum und wo dieses erkrankungs datum
uns nicht bekannt ist ersatzweise nach
melle datum
es gibt noch mal einen etwas anderen
blick auf die meldedaten die sie aus den
vergangenen wochen schon kennen vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit ich freue
mich auf ihre fragen
vielen dank schade wir fangen an mit ndr
wdr herr grill gehören sie uns der user
in deutschland an theologen empfiehlt
möglichst viele comic 19 verstorbene zu
obduzieren halten sie das für sinnvoll
welche fragen können dann beantwortet
werden
und warum haben sie ihre ursprüngliche
empfehlung nicht zu produzieren
inzwischen geändert ja ich fange mal
andersrum an mit der beantwortung vielen
dank für die frage also die
ursprüngliche empfehlung lautet sie ja
nicht nicht zu obduzieren sondern so
lautete das auch das nötigste zu
beschränken
unter dem eindruck das natürlich eine
obduktion auch ein gewisses
infektionsrisiko birgt das
schutzkleidung insgesamt auch knapp war
und dass das unter dem aspekt der
infektionsschutz ist dass es unserer
blick auf die dinge der primäre sagen
wir mal uns geboten schien und auch den
ländervertretern
es ist natürlich richtig gerade wenn die
erkrankung neu ist dann ist es wichtig
möglichst viel zu obduzieren unter den
entsprechenden er sicherheitsvorkehrung
und deswegen haben wir diese
empfehlungen dahingehend geändert dass
wir zurzeit eine empfehlung haben die
sich auf die äußere leichenschau
vereinigen bezieht und bei der inneren
leichenschau also der obduktion arbeiten
wir gemeinsam mit einer mit den büros
verband der pathologen auch
weitergehende empfehlungen aus um das
nochmal hier klar zu stellen
wir möchten auf keinen fall das wenig
obduziert wird im gegenteil eine
neuerkrankung wir brauchen wir viele
erkenntnisse sollte viel obduziert
werden wo immer möglich aber unter den
entsprechenden sicherheitsbedingungen
das ist eben auch wichtig und was kann
man sich daraus für erkenntnisse hoffen
nun es sieht so aus dass dieses virus
sehr viel mehr organe betreffen kann als
wir aus den ersten berichten vor allen
dingen aus china auch entnehmen konnten
es gibt berichte über herz beteiligung
es gibt berichte über
einen einfluss auf die blutgerinnung es
gibt berichte über auch beteiligung der
nieren und das sind natürlich alles
erkenntnisse die man jetzt systematisch
sammeln muss und eben auch durch
obduktionen dann auswerten muss um hier
ein vollständiges bild dieser coup 19
erkrankung mehr und mehr zu bekommen
vielen dank wenn sie dann das händchen
wieder anklicken damit das als erledigt
gekennzeichnet wird
herr reuters erwartet von reuters
anfrage zu zahlen
wir sind vielleicht sinnvoller in einem
gewissen die zettel an irgendein system
die standhalten kann es gibt also ich
verstehe ihre frage so ob nicht doch
eine langsame durchseuchung dann
sinnvoll wäre ja also das ist aus zwei
gründen schwierig also einmal dauert das
unheimlich lange wenn man eine
handhabbare zahl haben will das wird
jahre dauern dann wenn man in dem
bereich von einigen tausend infektionen
vielleicht pro tag bleibt oder wenigen
tausend das ist also das erste problem
und das zweite problem ist das natürlich
diese zahl nicht einfach zu steuern ist
diese die produktionszahl das ist eben
ein problem das system ist sehr träge
und eine wegnahme von maßnahmen kann
eben auch leicht wieder zu einem
überschießen die produktionszahl führen
ein gegensteuern würde dann entsprechend
auch mehrere wochen in
anspruch nehmen bis man den effekt
bemerkt insofern braucht man auf jeden
fall denke ich einen gewissen
sicherheitsabstand
und die idee einer langsamen
schleichenden durchseuchung scheitert
eben an
aus meiner sicht an den sehr langen
zeitraum die drei räumen die dafür
erforderlich werden eigentlich ist
einzig richtige also dass wenn man jetzt
rein nur die infektions epidemiologische
brille auf hätte dann wäre das
sicherlich so aber es gibt eben auch
andere umstände die zu berücksichtigen
sind und das sind eben die auswirkungen
auf die gesellschaft und auf die
wirtschaft und auch die muss man
natürlich ins kalkül ziehen auch die
haben ihre risiken und insofern denke
ich dass der jetzt gefundenen aus dieser
sich gefundene kompromiss zwischen den
landes und bundesregierungen in der
letzten woche ganz vernünftig ist aus
unserer sicht sollte natürlich dabei
letztendlich so vorgegangen werden durch
die schrittweise reduzierung der
maßnahmen dass eben diese
reproduktionsrate und die täglichen
fallzahlen und einen sicheren bereich
bleiben
vielen dank und wenn sie dann wieder auf
das handy symbol klicken damit sie aus
der liste entfernt werden jetzt haben
wir das zdf morgenmagazin herr jacobs zu
den bestehenden studien die unsere
bessere daten die von solchen besonders
viel versprechen
studie die das mit mal gegend und mitte
juni erwartet und deshalb die beiden
fragen erstens warum so spät wäre das
nicht früher möglich gewesen
beziehungsweise wenn sie die antikörper
das geld hätte man nicht vielleicht
früher einfach steht proben auch mit pcr
test repräsentativ schon ergebnisse
erzielen können ähnlich wie die
österreicher und die zweite frage wird
dort werden nicht personen oder erst
personen erst ab 18 jahren
in diesem großen studie mit eingeführt
weil ich kinder und jugendliche gerade
wenn ja wenn im blick auf kitas und
schulen
ja ich vermute dass eins nach dem
anderen zu beantworten die studien in
österreich und auch sind auch in
skandinavien durchgeführt worden solche
stichproben mit pcr in der bevölkerung
also wir werden so etwas auch machen
aber eben auch praktisch back to back
mit entsprechenden antikörper prüfungen
wenn man jetzt nur die pcr prüfung macht
da muss man sich schon bewusst sein dass
man da einen sehr kurzen zeitlichen
ausblick oder ausschnitt wählt es können
halt infizierte unter den probanden
seien die noch kein virus ausscheiden
also noch in der inkubationszeit sind
und bereits eine woche spätestens zwei
wochen nachdem man symptome entwickelt
hat scheidet man kein virus mehr aus man
hat dann also auch keine aussage ob eine
person in der vergangenheit diese
infektion gehabt hat es ist also ein
sehr kurzer oder ein sehr kurzes oder
kleines zeitfenster was man sich da an
schaute und deswegen haben wir uns
entschlossen eben lieber die proben etwa
in die studien etwas länger
vorzubereiten und dann eben in einigen
settings also in bei den sogenannten hot
spots sowohl pcr untersuchung als auch
antikörper untersuchung zu machen
die studien brauchen auch einfach eine
unterschiedlich lange vorbereitungszeit
repräsentative studien über deutschland
brauchen sicherlich etwas länger in der
vorbereitungszeit
die und das ist eben bei der
repräsentativen studie die ab mai
beginnen soll so auf der anderen seite
muss man auch sagen da muss die die
erwartbare zahl wenn man sich das
deutschlandweit betrachtet selbst wenn
man von einer untererfassung sagen wir
mal vom faktor drei oder fünf ausgeht
die ist klein sie ist recht klein und
insofern macht es auch aus unserer sicht
hätte es wenig sinn gemacht zu früh mit
dieser studie zu beginnen weil die
früher im infektionsgeschehen desto
weniger signal hätte man letztendlich in
deutschland gesehen auf repräsentative
ebene so dass uns der mai auch unter
diesem aspekt als ganz vernünftiges
datum erscheint und zur dritten frage
die die überlegung ist völlig richtig
die teile ich auch es ist jetzt zunächst
mal einfacher erwachsene die auch selbst
zustimmen können in diese studien
einzubinden aber im zuge der
gegenwärtigen diskussion denke ich
werden wir das auch noch mal überlegen
ob wir das ausweiten können auch auf
jugendliche und kinder unter 18 jahren
vielen dank und wenn sie noch ein
rasantes entente symbol denken ich bitte
um verständnis es waren schon sehr viele
fragen eigentlich ist nur eine frage und
maximal eine nachfrage zulässig die
deutsche presseagentur frau groos bitte
befürchtungen das ist jetzt eine zweite
flächendeckende berlin deutschland geben
könnte der bewährten vergangen
verstanden dass wir uns weiter er stand
nicht in grenzen aus briefen bleibt also
ich das denke ich haben sie dann
vielleicht nicht ganz richtig verstanden
also ich würde diese grundsätzliche
gefahr dass bei einer vorschnellen
rücknahme sämtlicher kontakt
reduzierende maßnahmen oder auch eines
grossteils das zu einer zweiten welle
kommen kann das würde ich ausdrücklich
auch so sehen wie hat osten das sieht
man muss sich letztendlich vorstellen
wir haben hier was wir messen und was
wir säen letztendlich an den fällen und
auch am er 0
das ist die interaktion zwischen erreger
eigenschaften wie infektiös ist dieser
erreger und menschlichem verhalten und
dieses menschliche verhalten
da gibt es eben die komponenten die wir
gesagt haben abstand hygiene und so
weiter dieses menschliche verhalten ist
in der lage das haben wir in den letzten
wochen ja gesehen
die übertragung deutlich zu reduzieren
das heißt aber auch der anderen seite
auch weniger vernünftig sage ich mal in
diesem zusammenhang oder je weniger wir
das virus hindern durch unser verhalten
von mensch zu mensch zu springen um so
mehr wird das virus auch wieder auf
seine eigentliche reproduktion style die
basis reproduktion style also die die
eintritt wenn man eben keine maßnahmen
ergreift zurückfallen und die ila es
irgendwo zwischen zwei und drei und das
heißt wenn wir also alle weiter jetzt so
tun als ob das problem überwunden wäre
dann werden wir wieder einen ausbruch
haben das ist ziemlich sicher wir kommen
nur weiter über die runden wenn wir
maßnahmen weiter einhalten
das sind auf jeden fall die maßnahmen
die die man persönlich
ich dazu beitragen kann ich hatte sie
eben ausführlich erwähnt und auch noch
weitere maßnahmen auf gesellschaftsebene
und da muss man eben sehen durch
schrittweise zurücknahme bis zu welchen
schritt man hier gehen kann um das virus
noch weiter unter kontrolle zu halten
das risiko dass es wieder zu vermehrten
infektionen kommt ist dabei gegeben und
da müssen wir eben ganz genau aufpassen
und das hat sich auch die
bundesregierung bereits betont vielen
dank
wir gehen zur welt nachrichtensender hat
ja also die reproduktionsrate ist sehr
wichtig also wie gesagt ja im grunde
nichts weiter als dass irgendwann die
über 1 ist dass es dann zu einem
wachstum der epidemie kommt wenn sie
eins ist das von tag zu tag im grunde
ein mit einer gleichbleibenden fallzahl
zu rechnen ist und wenn sie unter 1 ist
dann eben von tag zu tag mit einer
sinkenden fallzahlen das heißt auf der
anderen seite auch dass die
reproduktionsrate nicht alles sein kann
denn wenn man jeden tag sehr viele fälle
hat und dann die reproduktionsrate
versucht auf 1 einzustellen dann wird
man eben in der zukunft weiterhin so
viele fälle haben also man muss auch die
fallzahl berücksichtigen weil die fälle
ja auch eine zeit brauchen bis sie dann
schwer krank werden dann liegen sie
ganze zeit auf intensivstation kommt
also dazu eine radierung effekt und wenn
man eben ich nenne jetzt eine zahl die
es jetzt einfach gegriffen von 15 oder
20 tausend neun fällen jeden tag hat hat
dann die reproduktionsrate auf 1 dann
wird man eben auch in ein problem
hineinlaufen
man muss also versuchen und das ist
unsere empfehlung die reproduktionsrate
unter 1 zu senken und gleichzeitig auch
niedrige fallzahlen zu erreichen
alles zurück zu fahren das ist eine sehr
schwierige frage
selbst wenn es uns gelänge
selbst wenn es uns gelänge keine fälle
mehr in deutschland zu haben
dann wird es virus ja noch in der welt
vorhanden sein
das heißt wir müssen also bis ein
impfstoff da ist von dem wir alle nicht
wissen wann er kommt und ob er kommt
müssen wir letztendlich und so verhalten
dass wir infektionen vermeiden denn auch
wenn wir in deutschland keine fälle mehr
haben ist es durchaus möglich dass das
virus wieder eingeführt werden könnte
unerkannt und das ist dann zu neuen
ausbrüchen kommt und um die von
vorneherein zu vermeiden
es ist sicherlich sinnvoll die
hygienemaßnahmen die verhaltensregeln
eben auf lange frist weiter zu weiter
einfach zu praktizieren in der
bevölkerung wenn wir irgendwann keine
fälle in deutschland mehr haben und
keine lokale virusvermehrung mehr haben
dann kann man sicherlich die die
gesellschaftlichen maßnahmen diese
kontakt reduzieren den maßnahmen auf
gesellschaftsebene immer weiter
zurückfahren möglicherweise sogar bis
auf null
aber man muss auch dann eine weiter eine
bereitschaft haben das wieder
hochzufahren
wenn es eben wieder zur ausbruch hin
kommen könnte das werden wir ganz sicher
eigentlich nur verhindern können wenn
wir einen impfstoff haben
vielen dank wegen zu n-tv haaretz ja wir
haben sie offenbar die strategie nicht
mehr flächen gekauft sondern es ist eine
kurve flacher viel sondern muss
ausrollten habe ich das erstens richtig
verstanden und dann die frage müssten
daher niemanden gegeben der epidemie in
deutschland bilden oder wie lange wird
diese strategie teuer und was sie da
gesagt herren heiß hatte deutschland
teilhaben
ja also im moment denke ich sind wir
noch bei bettencourt also die kurve
sollte aber soweit wie möglich runter
also ich hatte eben eigentlich so
gemeint dass selbst wenn wir eben in
deutschland keine fälle mehr haben
das wird kein stamp auch das virus seien
auf globaler ebene betrachtet sondern
wir müssen eben immer damit rechnen weil
das virus weltweit verbreitet ist dass
dieses virus auch wieder zu uns
zurückkommt wir werden immer mit diesem
virus rechnen müssen und in den in dem
sinne halte ich es im moment für wenig
realistisch das virus ganz auszurotten
und eine ausrottung nur in deutschland
ist eben es eben nur der halbe weg und
würde letztendlich zu keiner sicherheit
wie langfristig hält führen die wird
letztendlich dann wenn wir eine impfung
also eine dass ich denke das wird
sicherlich viele monate dauern bis wir
eine eine lösung haben die die uns
erlaubt jetzt wieder wie vorher
ganz ohne an dieses virus zu denken in
den alltag zu gehen
man kann sich verschiedene lösungen
vorstellen die ideale lösung hatte ich
erwähnt das wäre ein ein wirksamer
impfstoff wenn der käme es gibt auch
alternative lösungen zum beispiel könnte
auch ein medikament letztendlich
entdeckt werden und entwickelt werden
das prophylaktisch oder eingenommen
werden kann oder eben bei infektionen
entsprechend eine einer heilung insofern
erreicht dass der dass das virus seien
schrecken verliert auch das wäre eine
eine möglichkeit aber solange es diese
möglichkeiten nicht gibt werden wir das
durch unser verhalten steuern müssen
vielen dank jetzt gehen wir zum reporter
rainer kurlemann
fragen zur seite
es scheint ja offenbar unterschiedliche
inhalte leute also die frage ist dann zb
ist oder dass kinder das trio steht das
nicht zur diskussion die auf die ersten
formierten und spricht einen teil davon
liegt ist weil wir jetzt schon einen
enden stamm und wenn es ihm nicht
ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher ob
ich das alles richtig verstanden habe
aus akustischen gründen die frage ging
andy richtungen kinder
ob letztendlich die infektionsrate und
die verbreitung bei kindern ähnlich zu
sehen ist wie bei erwachsenen so habe
ich das verstanden ist das richtig also
wir wissen dass wir wissen aus einigen
studien dass das kinder
das weiß man vor allen dingen aus
kontakt nach verfolgungs untersuchungen
dass kinder in ähnlichem prozentsatz
infiziert sind wie erwachsene
das fällt meist nicht so auf weil die
eben kaum symptome haben und deshalb
nicht aktiv danach gesucht wird aber im
rahmen von kontakt nachverfolgung sieht
man eben einen prozentualen anteil von
kindern die infiziert sind die ähnlich
hoch ist wie erwachsenen bei erwachsenen
diese kinder haben dann keine symptome
haben aber im rachen ähnliche hohe
replikations werte des virus wie eben
auch erwachsene und auf der anderen
seite wissen wir das
gerade auch die übertragung solcher
symptomatische personen bevor sie
letztendlich symptome entwickeln was bei
erwachsenen dann ja häufiger der fall
ist eine rolle spielt für das
infektionsgeschehen und aus diesem
zusammenhang kann man also schließen
dass die kinder auch eine gewisse rolle
für die übertragung spielen auch wenn
sie selbst durch symptome praktisch kaum
in erscheinung treten
die untersuchung welchen anteil sie
jetzt haben zur virusvermehrung in der
gesellschaft da gibt es bisher keine
keine studien die da eindeutige aussagen
machen das liegt daran dass die
schulschließung in den meisten staaten
zu den ersten maßnahmen mit gehörten die
ergriffen worden sind aber eben auch
nicht alleine sondern im bündel so dass
man eben schlecht beurteilen kann was
die einzelne maßnahme dann tatsächlich
gebracht hat in diesem fall eben
schulschließung für modellierung ist das
sieht das ein bisschen anders aus es
gibt modellierungen die versuchen den
einfluss von schulschließungen auf das
gesamtgeschehen zu bewerten
die kommt schon etwas uneinheitlichen
aussage gehen aber letztendlich in die
richtung dass es auch eine komponente
ist die durchaus eine wirkung hat wenn
man versucht die die kurve eben nach
unten zu drücken wie wir eben auch
gesagt
vielen dank wir gehen zum swr der daten
ist diese kapazitäten
[Musik]
ja also die lieferschwierigkeiten gibt
es regional gesehen immer noch das ist
also schon immer noch ein problem
es ist auch weiterhin so dass die test
kapazitäten regional unterschiedlich
ausgenutzt werden weil einfach auch das
infektionsgeschehen auf der einen seite
regional unterschiedlich ist und die
test kapazitäten eben auch nicht
hundertprozentig homogenen über die
ganzen regionen in deutschland verteilt
sind
dennoch ist es so dass ich denke mehr
getestet werden könnte und wir würden
uns das auch wünschen und wir sind auch
gegenwärtig in abstimmungen dazu ob wir
unsere test empfehlungen entsprechend
anpassen
das ist noch nicht ganz entschieden aber
bereits jetzt steht ja auf unseren test
kriterien die sie im internet nachlesen
können dass wenn ausreichend test
kapazitäten vorhanden sind im grunde
jeder atemwegserkrankung jeder schwere
auf cupid 19 und auf der ask auf zwei
virus untersucht werden sollte und wir
überlegen und sie war diese diese
indikation eben noch etwas betonen
können vorrangig sollen natürlich
diejenigen getestet werden die
entsprechend schwer erkrankt sind aber
wenn eben die möglichkeit ist dann
sollte neben aller atemwegserkrankungen
entsprechend getestet werden das würden
wir uns wünschen
und ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
hier in zukunft auch noch irgendwie die
test praxis die die wir ja nur indirekt
beeinflussen können sich auch noch
entsprechend ändert
also grundsätzlich ist kann man sich das
gut vorstellen auf jeden fall dann wenn
er an diesen pflegeeinrichtungen
wenn es da ausbrüche gibt dann ist das
auf jeden fall eine eine maßnahme wie
man in erwägung ziehen sollte und
entsprechend auch durchführen sollte
weil eben einige personen eben schon das
virus aus scheint bevor sie selbst
erkranken
ob man das als generelle
vorsorgemaßnahme macht da müsste man
noch mal genauer nach rechnen denn ich
glaube dann würden auch die 760.000
testen möglicherweise etwas knapp werden
aber grundsätzlich sollte man auch
spätestens dann wenn verdachtsfälle
auftauchen oder ausbrüche 1 kein
screening in entsprechenden
einrichtungen durchführen
vielen dank die taz herr kreutzfeldt die
beteiligten erforderlich sein
diese werden aus ihrer sicht in der
derzeitigen situation vertretbar sind
viele tests für den 7 nicht unbedingt
notwendigen dingen die bundesliga
betrieb zu verwenden
und vielleicht auch noch wie viele tests
werden aus dichtes kaliber insgesamt auf
den wirklichen wert die 700.000
überkapazität haben ausreichend oder
günstige sagen von der echte walter
kolbow kontakt mehr
ja also das ist
eine schwierige frage ich denke man
sollte die tester dort anwenden wo es
medizinisch sinnvoll ist und mehr im
detail ins detail kann ich bei dieser
frage eigentlich nicht gehen und aus
unserer sicht ist es letztendlich eine
ist es eben wünschenswert jede
respiratorische erkrankungen jedenfalls
zur zeit wo gar keine erkältungssaison
haben jede respiratorische erkrankungen
jede atemwegserkrankung abzuklären ob es
cobit 19 sein könnte um sensitive fälle
zu entdecken und es ist sicherlich auch
sinnvoll in krankenhäusern alten
einrichtung screening untersuchungen
durchzuführen wenn man das machen kann
das würde bedeuten dass die test
kapazitäten sicherlich höher liegen
müssten als als eine million pro woche
genaue zahl kann ich ihnen da zurzeit
nicht nennen
das wird aber so einfach nicht möglich
sein weil selbst wenn die apparative
ausstattung gegeben ist das
verbrauchsmaterial ist eben weltweit im
moment nachgefragt und es ist nicht so
ohne weiteres möglich dass entsprechend
die produktion hoch zu verlieren so dass
ich da einfach praktische probleme sehen
vielen dank wir haben das auch
wahrgenommen und rätseln wo es herkommt
jetzt der ärzte nachrichtendienst härter
frau mißlbeck
keine frage eine frage pro person und
eine nachfrage sind zulässig wir bitten
um verständnis
die anderen wollen auch nicht drankommen
personal seien diese zahlen kommen und
ob die sich nach berufsgruppen und
bundesländern aufschlüsseln lassen wir
haben das direkt in den unteren
abgesehen die das rp online so verhält
kann dort aber keine hinweise gefunden
die folge es vielleicht auch nicht jetzt
direkt beantwortet werden aber
mitgenommen obwohl da die anwesenden
kriegen können
zweite frage ist wie welche gene in
berlin sieht ist es ob die zahl der
gleichzeitig irgendwann auch nicht mehr
angestiegen ist von spannungen abgesehen
bei und bewundert von den zehn prozent
stationär und einem bruchteil davon
intensivmedizinisch behandelt wird den
angaben der senatsverwaltung zum folge
geben denn diese konstanz und intensiv
hat das aussetzen von planbaren op ist
zum beispiel in krankenhäusern ist die
frage ehrlich gesagt weder akustisch und
dadurch auch inhaltlich nicht gut
verstanden könnten sie das nochmal
wiederholen vielleicht etwas kürzer in
berlin ist die zahl der gleichzeitig
infizierten seit drei wochen konstant
im krankenhaus und die frage ist
schlicht wenn man so in konstanz
erreicht hat ist das kein kriterium um
beschränkungen zu lokal also die die
beschränkungen werden ja zur zeit
gelockert genau mit dieser überlegung
wir haben relativ niedrigen fallzahlen
und wir haben eine ehre dass um 1 ist
also möglichst sollte es unter 1 1 und
konstante fallzahlen bedeutet ja
letztendlich nichts anderes als ein eher
um 1 und das ist ja genau der anders ja
jetzt bundesweit diese diese lockerung
zu erwägen und auch mit denen
schrittweise zu beginnen
[Musik]
ja auch das wird ja zurzeit überlegt und
wie weit man wieder mit elektiven
eingriffen beginnen kann
das ist letztendlich eine frage der
krankenhausplanung aber auch diese
überlegungen sind ja jetzt angestoßen
und man wird sich sicherlich überlegen
wie man das auch schrittweise macht denn
es ist sicherlich auch so dass man wenn
man mehrere dinge an mehreren
stellschrauben gleichzeitig dreht man
auch aufpassen muss dass man hier keine
keine übersteuerung eingeht aber im
vorsichtigen was könnte ich mir das
durchaus vorstellen ist aber sache der
krankenhausplan vielen dank wir bitten
hat auch noch herrn kreutzfeldt wieder
das händchen zu und dazu nehmen die
frage war ja abgearbeitet auch den erz
nachrichtendiensten bitte und wir gehen
zum medico direkt herr hering sich die
[Musik]
investitionsmaßnahmen auch die aus
grundsätzlichen überlegungen ist ja
offensichtlich dass die monetäre seite
stünde es gegangen
zehn millionen und die dokumentierten
verfangen tag zugrunde liegen sind das
größte als 5000 von tag für das meinen
für die größe und 10.000 bundesbürger
das ist also die geldinstitute bereits
erwähnt dass jemand die hier sind da ist
gegen 5000 volk könne nicht weiter oben
gelegenen sein benzin oder 20.000 sultan
jetzt einfach mal in den raum gestellt
die durchseuchung geschwindigkeit
wesentlich vermindert das heißt es
durchs ziel
ab sieben jahren als er eine solche
situationen fehlt eigentlich alles und
man muss auf den start warten und wir
wissen auf der anderen seiten dass die
behandlungsoptionen als brennstoff oder
medikamente sicherlich nicht von einem
jahr wahrscheinlich länger tatsächlich
greifen können
die frage ist welche
präventionsmaßnahmen können und müssen
justizbehörden damit die
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit einerseits
unterhalb in der schulischen belastung
des gesundheitssystems bleiben
andererseits aber ein gesellschaftliches
und wirtschaftliches leben oder konkrete
nachfragen ob dazu welche rolle könnte
bei der leistung der aktion ist meist
die ensinger spielen ja also sie haben
völlig recht
auch nicht nur aus diesem praktischen
grund ist das schwierig wird der
durchseuchung sondern die durchseuchung
würde eben auch entsprechend natürlich
viele schwere krankheitsfälle und auch
todesfälle bedeuten
und insofern ist das ist das keine
strategie die wir verfolgen und von der
ich auch nicht wüsste dass die in
deutschland verfolgt wird eine einer
durchseuchung eben gezielt irgendwie
anzustreben oder zu steuern
die frage welche maßnahmen sind zu
lockern und welche sollten bestehen
bleiben ich hatte vorhin schon versucht
zu beantworten
ich gehe davon aus dass die persönlichen
verhaltensweisen erstmal als als als
grundelement auf jeden fall erhalten
bleiben müssen das heißt dass man eben
abstand zu anderen sucht dass man eben
die husten hygiene weiter einheit die
die händehygiene und eben als
zusätzliche komponente in dieser
strategie dem mund nasen der deckung
wenn man im öffentlichen raum mit
mehreren personen zusammen ist das ist
sozusagen die basis und wie viel man
dann von diesen gesellschaftlichen
maßnahmen davon wegnehmen kann das muss
man im grunde jetzt schritt für schritt
probieren das kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
das kann auch keiner
es gibt keine verlässliche studie die
sagt diese oder jene maßnahme in jedem
land bedeutet eine reduktion des herum
so und so viel so dass man sich das
irgendwie ausrechnen könnte man muss es
letztendlich ausprobieren und das ziel
ist natürlich das virus unter kontrolle
zu behalten
bei gleichzeitig möglichst wenig
einschränkungen des öffentlichen lebens
das ist ja auch der grund so habe ich
das jedenfalls verstanden dass sich die
bundesregierung mit den
landesregierungen über dieses thema
jetzt in den nächsten wochen alle zwei
wochen zusammensetzen wird um hier genau
das zu beraten
das kann ich also auch nicht vorhersehen
die tracing app ist kann sicher eine
wichtige rolle spielen ich möchte mal
die frage andersherum beginnen die
intensive fall findung und die intensive
kontaktsuche das wird sicherlich ein
oder ist ganz eine ganz wichtige
komponente in der strategie auch in den
nächsten wochen und monaten
denn wenn immer fälle auftreten besteht
natürlich die gefahr des ausbruchs und
um den zu für die zu vermindern müssen
die fälle gefunden und isoliert werden
und die kontakte eben auch gefunden und
entsprechenden absonderung damit sie
nicht weitere anstecken gebracht werden
und das ist das ist das prinzip und das
wird sicherlich durch eine tracing app
kann das erleichtert werden
aber es ist nicht so dass wenn diese
tracing app nun nicht kommt oder in den
ersten paar wochen später kommt dass man
diese maßnahme nicht trotzdem
durchführen könnte diese maßnahme ist
klassisches epidemiologische handwerk
das wird vereinfacht durch digitale
durch digitale instrumente aber
grundsätzlich ist es auch so möglich
durch befragung der leute und dem indem
man eben dann den kontakten mit dem
telefon oder auch durchaus suchen in
ihrer häuslichen umgebung dann mit denen
spricht vielen dank wir gehen zu hören
maier vom focus interessieren sie
eine einen starken abfall von menschen
gibt die sich wegen herzinfarkten
schlager verändern notrufen beiden ist
ihnen dabei etwas tisches und hand bzw
können die das werden sie das rp immer
sie können sich vorstellen dass man in
ein paar wochen dreht wissen wir jetzt
dass sie diese teilen der welt sind die
vorüber und sehen ja also die diese
berichte die haben wir natürlich auch
wahrgenommen dass das patientenaufkommen
insgesamt und auch mit klassischen
notfällen zur zeit geringer zu sein
scheint mit statistisch belastbare
zahlen können wir ihnen das zurzeit was
das bedeutet annan schwersten
erkrankungen oder auch todesfälle können
wir ihnen das zurzeit nicht sagen
wir werden das thema aber bearbeiten im
rahmen der gesundheitsberichterstattung
und die entsprechenden quellen die uns
da zur verfügung stehen eben hier
auswerten und das wird sicherlich so
sein dass wir dazu in einigen wochen
mehr sagen können
vielen dank beginn zu bloomberg news
[Musik]
also ich wenn wir weiterhin das virus so
gut kontrollieren können wie es zur zeit
der fall ist dann werden wir den effekt
in der über sterblichkeit vermutlich
kaum sehen bzw eben nur sehr marginal
wir müssen das ja vergleichen oder
können dass vergleiche zum beispiel mit
der enden mit der influenza in einer
influenza saison werden aber eben bis zu
20 prozent der bevölkerung infiziert mit
entsprechend dann auch deutlich
geringeren todesfälle todesfall raten
aber mit entsprechend daneben auch
todesfällen und das sehen wir ja in der
regel in der über sterblichkeit zwischen
3000 und 10.000 fällen gelegentlich
manchmal auch mehr
aber die fallzahl in deutschland an coop
mit 19 fällen ist ja insgesamt so gering
und auch die todeszahl dass das
vermutlich wenn es gelingt das virus
weiter unter kontrolle zu halten wir das
in diesen mortalitätsrate statistiken
kaum sehen sie hatten das ist anders in
anderen ländern mit sehr vielen fällen
da kann man das jetzt sehen in dieser
euro momo ist das bereits zu sehen aber
in deutschland sind die fallzahlen noch
relativ gering und wir hoffen ja dass
weiter stabilisieren zu können sodass
vielleicht da eine kleine zack bekommt
aber das wird wahrscheinlich jetzt keine
keine große welle werden vielen dank der
wenn dick von svt was ist svt bitte also
ich denke das ist in der gerade in der
anfangsphase war es ist es wichtig dass
man eben sensitive testet um eben
möglichst viele fälle zu identifizieren
und die dann auch zu isolieren und und
die kontakte eben zu ermitteln dann ist
es sicherlich so dass es schwieriger
wird durch diese test gezielte
regulierungsmaßnahmen vorzunehmen wenn
man eine ein sehr heftiges
infektionsgeschehen hat auch da ist es
natürlich wichtig jeder fall den man aus
dem infektionsgeschehen nimmt verursacht
wieder weniger folge fälle und wirkt
sich positiv auf das gesamtgeschehen aus
und wenn man jetzt wie wir hoffen in
eine phase kommt wo man das virus wieder
richtig unter kontrolle hat dann nimmt
das natürlich an bedeutung noch mal zu
das ziel muss sein einen so großen so
großen anteil wie möglich von
infektionsfällen zu identifizieren durch
einen test und dann durch diese
infektion szenischen maßnahmen zu
verhindern dass diese person oder deren
kontakte zu weiteren infektionswellen
kommen geführt
ich denke also dass das dass das testen
insgesamt für die kontrolle eine sehr
große rolle spielt man muss natürlich
sehen dass wenn man ein sehr heftiges
bevölkerungsweite das
infektionsgeschehen hat dann wird es
immer unwahrscheinlicher dass man auch
wirklich in relevanten maßstab ihrer
infektionsfälle identifizieren kann
das ist aber nach allem was wir wissen
bisher in deutschland so nicht gewesen
selbst wenn man jetzt von einer
untererfassung ausgeht dann sind die
test kapazitäten der immer noch
ausreichend gewesen um eine
identifikation zu ermöglichen
man kriegt nie alle fälle weil manche
gehen einfach nicht zum arzt
aber die die zum arzt gehen
die konnten alle getestet werden am ende
vielen dank herr schmidt vom radio
münchen entschuldigung frau schmidt
[Musik]
monaten stabil bei einer options- zahl
von 1 hatten sie vorher gesagt sie
würden aus epidemiologischer sicht wäre
des bewohners ausrotten jetzt ist es
immunsystem ja eine fähigkeit des
menschen sich an die umwelt anzupassen
mit den jetzigen kontakt einschränkungen
nehmen wir aber im augenblick der
gesellschaft ein von den kindern die
möglichkeit sich nicht nur mit dem
promoter virus sondern auch mit allen
anderen wie ein auseinanderzusetzen
wir sehen das ja an den rapiden abfall
wie die buben in ihrer rasse zu den
atemwegserkrankungen internet ist in den
letzten jahren
daraufhin sind die fähigkeit sich mit
dem folgegenerationen der birne
auseinanderzusetzen ist es unter anderem
sollte nicht ein eingriff in das
immunsystem der kinder und der ganzen
gesellschaft wie mit in unsere
überlegungen einbeziehen müssen
wenn also jetzt mal zunächst auf die
anderen atemwegserkrankungen ein wenn
wir das jetzt so weitermachen würden
monate oder jahre dann wäre das
sicherlich so dass das die kinder dann
weniger gelegenheit hätten sich mit
diesen erregern auseinanderzusetzen und
das dann später nachholen würden und in
der tat ist es auch so dass viele
erkrankungen jahren kindesalter
viruserkrankungen kindesalter etwas
milder verlaufen als bei erwachsenen
sehen sie die klassischen
kinderkrankheiten aber es ist ja nicht
so dass jetzt die schulschließung ewig
weitergehen sollen das sind jetzt wenn
man die ferien mal abzieht in
deutschland drei oder vier wochen je
nachdem die schulschließungen waren und
er ist es jetzt schon wieder die
diskussion wie diese schulschließung
aufgehoben werden also ich denke das ist
keine so kohl kein so großer zeitraum
dass man dem immunsystem das das
training wenn sie so wollen hier
grundsätzlich für eine ganze generation
ja verwehren würde das wird ja wieder
einsetzen
auch einfach dadurch dass die kinder
dann ja auch
wieder beginnen mehr am alltag
teilzunehmen und miteinander zu spielen
und ähnlich sahen das jahrelang machen
würde dann hätten sie vermögen
vermutlich an der einen oder anderen
stelle recht aber das ist ja nicht
abzusehen was das was das kona virus
selbst angeht ist es ja so dass dieses
virus doch was man wenn man es auf
bevölkerungs ebene betrachtet eben recht
pathogen ist das macht eine erhebliche
anzahl von patienten krank und auch eine
erhebliche anzahl von patienten wenden
schwer krank und wenn die anzahl der
infizierten eben entsprechend hoch ist
dann hat man eben auch entsprechend
viele schwerkranke patienten jetzt die
überlegung anzustreben man müsse das
immunsystem und das nützt ja nichts wenn
man das individuum macht sozusagen der
population hier entsprechend anpassen
würde aber bedeuten dass man das in kauf
nimmt anders kann man das ja nicht
erreichen
und da ist meine einschätzung und auch
die einschätzung vieler kollegen das
wäre ja im prinzip wieder die gezielte
durchseuchung dass die gezielte
durchseuchung eigentlich bei diesem
virus sowie sich uns präsentiert und
auch wenn man mit den ärzten spricht die
patienten auf station behandeln
eigentlich nicht zu rechtfertigen ist
vielen dank wir haben jetzt noch drei
anfragen dann aber ganz kurz bitte
zeigt wenn der verwendete test
ausschließlich den koran virus also saß
co2 beim menschen und wenn ja wenn dann
jemand positiv getestet wurde wird dann
auch die konzentration und das
verhältnis zu den anderen angezeigt die
hier auch oft mit in diesem milieu vor
sind ja also der test den wir jetzt
anwenden für die diagnostik das ist eine
polymerasekettenreaktion das ist ein
erreger direkt nachweis der spezifisch
auf dieses auf diese sass koch 2 weil er
in einer spezifischen region genregion
entsprechend ansetzt das kann man auch
quantifizieren man kann also messen wie
viel virus da zum beispiel im rachen
jetzt kriegen wir herzlich vorhanden ist
aber der ist eben spezifisch und weist
nur dieses virus nach nicht die anderen
corona werden die auch möglicherweise
zirkulieren oder zirkuliert haben in
diesem winter
das kann man auch nachweisen dann müsste
man aber einen anderen pcr test machen
und das ist eben da nicht dieser saß
kohona virus test davon zu unterscheiden
ist ein antikörper nachweis das heißt
also man ist die immunreaktion des
körpers auf einen virus und diese
antikörper nachweise ganz generell
madonna viren
da muss man eben aufpassen dass diese
antikörper nachweisen gut unterscheiden
können zwischen den verschiedenen
coronaviren das können nicht alle gäste
gleich gut es gibt testet das weniger
gut können es gibt andere die das besser
können das wird zurzeit eben evaluiert
und das ist dann natürlich auch
voraussetzung unter gezielte aussagen
machen zu können
darin war dann von spezifität wenn man
über diese über diese kreuz reaktivität
spricht oder eben nicht
diese tests werden aber zurzeit für die
diagnostik ob jemand akut an einer
infektion erkrankt ist oder nicht nicht
eingesetzt beziehungsweise nur dann in
ganz besonderen settings also man zb
verlaufs untersuchungen macht von
patienten im rahmen von studien wenn die
plötzlich antikörper positiv waren und
vorher diesen antikörper nicht hatten
aber in der normalen diagnostik werden
sie nicht eingesetzt
vielen dank wie gesagt noch 3
anfragenden jeweils mit der bitte um
kurze frage und auch kurze antwort
guntrum herr brune und locarno
wir fangen mit den bonnern tragen sie
noch die redaktion gerade zu bleibenden
schäden führen kann auch bei menschen
die nicht beachtet werden mussten haben
sieht also schon nähere informationen
also mehr als dass wir diese berichte
zur kenntnis genommen haben kann ich
ihnen leider im moment noch nicht sagen
also noch keine statistik wie häufig das
gefühl ist ich kann ihnen auch noch
keine aussagen darüber machen wie dann
diese sage ich mal längere
längerfristigen lungenschäden wie sie
sich auswirken auf die gesundheit der
patienten auf die funktionsfähigkeit der
lunge
das sind alles noch dinge die im moment
im fluss sind das haben aber wir und
auch die anderen ärzte die behandeln und
die universitäten die entsprechende
studien durchführen
im blick und werden das untersuchen
darum seien sie noch bitte ihre
redaktion dazu irgendwo ich habe trage
schade sie die frage hier getan
warum ist das aus wie ist es denn
sinnvoll diesen test berichten zu lassen
ich hatte gesagt dass ich glaube dass
diese texte für medizinische
indikationen eingesetzt werden sollten
das ist das was ich dazu sagen kann
das heißt wenn ich das richtig verstehe
ja dass unter den testern zu werden
wenn eine medizinische indikation hat
gerne wenn er teil eines ausbruchs
geschehen ist auch aber ich sehe nicht
warum bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen ob
die nun sportler sind oder man kann sich
auch alles andere ausdenken was
möglicherweise ein gewisses
gesellschaftliches interesse hat warum
die routinemäßig gescreent werden
sollten vielen dank
ich bitte die frage sollte sehr kurz
sein wir sind schon ein bisschen über
der zeit
[Musik]
also wie gesagt mit dem test testen wir
das saas corona virus 2 ja das ist ja
das was jetzt auf diesen aufbruch macht
und mit diesem test testen wir jetzt
keine anderen coronaviren davon aber
jetzt noch mal unabhängig die frage so
verstehe ich das gibt es da mutationen
bei diesem saß corona virus zwei die man
irgendwie regional zuordnen kann
das möchte ich so beantworten es gibt
immer kleine mutationen bei den viren
der test der benutzt wird ist in einer
region die sehr wenig mutiert so dass
das stabil auch immer nachweisbar ist
dass dieses virus
gleichwohl kann man die viren
untereinander falsch wenn man das
vergleicht genetisch kann man die
voneinander unterscheiden diese kleinen
mutation man kann also bestimmte strenge
nachweisen
das sind aber letztendlich
unterscheidungen die für die biologie
des virus und wies auf den menschen
einwirkt also wie krank es macht und wie
infektiös ist und weiteres keinen
unterschied machen und das sind reine
merkmale wo man die die infektionsketten
mit unterscheiden kann aber keine
biologisch relevanten mutation
[Musik]
der unterschied zwischen ja das wäre
gerade das wäre ja gerade so ein
biologisch relevante unterschied wenn
man dieses virus angehören anschaut so
ein unterschied ist bisher nicht
festgestellt worden
das liegt eher an wird's faktoren auf
dieser das den letztendlich die
erkrankung in verschiedenen
altersgruppen und unter verschiedenen
personengruppen unterschiedlich stark
und unterschiedlich mit unterschiedlich
viel komplikationen verlaufen kann
vielen dank vielen dank vielen dank wir
bitten um verständnis eine nachfrage
profession
wir sind jetzt auch schon über derzeit
und bedanken uns bei allen zuschauern
oder zuhörern und sehen uns oder hören
uns am dienstag wieder
vielen dank
[Musik]